hey how's it going breasts - Peter Pan
welcome to the scariest game the first
game was called one final breath it just
came out in an episodic little
thingamajigger let's give it a go so oh
god I'm scared already in I don't know I
suppose the first important thing you
need to know is that I had a daughter
her name was Carrie Anne are you just
gonna let that burger sit there man I
blame myself
poor burger you're just staring at his
soul
[Music]
lonely I'm mr. lonely
ah here we are in oh my god Mike
miss cutting what is this text on the
screen
oh my I am slowly s light flashlight how
do I get in ah how do I get in I should
look around there's nowhere to look
around oh wait are you oh my god oh my
god
I have to do this no not yet so this is
the passcode
what is it site 19 xxxx
well I have a key to this room Oh
apparently I did hi oh there they are
eight and six okay and then there was
the constant feeling that trying to
solve a puzzle
did I open it I think I did it baby they
bit pepper dip it boo yay the [ __ ] was
that one of the kids rooms yeah this
place was huge one room of many and the
most rundown wait what what's going on
but what was that as we say in German
what was that I do not know
whenever I get goosebumps and sweat I
get really itchy and I got that right
now in case you were wondering there you
go you're welcome
why is it so quiet they the ambience
loop stop what are you guys doing anyway
it's not how you exercise not the best
game I ever played it has potential but
it's really poorly optimized and it's
making me nauseous just going near it
okay now we going to the next game yeah
that's what's so great about this show
if the game isn't good enough we can
play well mystic school night blights
this was suggested by many of you bros
so I hope it will be good night lights
you play as a small child and you must
protect your family and yourself from an
infestation of night blades there's a
night flight under your parents and your
sister's beds oh god what do I do
remember to feed them toys when they
growl what what is this game all right
we gotta feed the night flight some toys
I'll bring your this chap yes very good
Timmy Timmy did tamagochi and I spit it
back I am with Satan now no kami no what
was that sound Tammy I'm sure Oh God
please accept Timmy and don't hurt me I
see him bridge where's the fridge this
freaky man oh I don't know I don't like
that that was not supposed to be open
hey you better close it right away
I see you in there you [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
adorable here have Tammy you're horrible
oh my god mites yeah please I don't have
enough sweets no no but my last toy
Tammy the dinosaur tail oh god no Tammy
[Music]
your parents died Jesus Christ they
should call this night blunt I like that
it was a really interesting game
interesting concept maybe he'll make
like a full version maybe that was a
full version I'm so sorry
cool okay it's original now final game
of this evening it's called oh my god
watch it what was that what is that is
it raining cows already my favorite
horror game of all time it's free beta
and you can vote on it on Steam
greenlight al pages all pictures the
five books the greatest game of all time
free ok no no no this is the best game I
move slower I move so slow holy [ __ ]
you are further look remember the
earlier of the five books following it
okay no the Texas gone now ah [ __ ] me in
the [ __ ]
don't do that okay here we go we're
going I am father gascoigne
and I shall cleanse these lands oh my
god it's like Nosferatu [ __ ] yes some
creatures are unstoppable ha
no creature isn't stoppable for fun I
guess gonna I got myself a [ __ ]
shower day why is the game running so
slowly isn't it running slow motion
it must be my graphic card and five
books to be able to kill the witch I
hate witches have a nice journey thank
you
I think I'm faster if I jump okay okay
now is festive begun bottom shut down oh
it's just a cow big odd steak all right
let's not shoot anything more it might
be innocent
you never know this land perhaps are you
innocent then don't run holy [ __ ] it
exploded the [ __ ] was that I need to
find myself a [ __ ] book oh my [ __ ]
dick
oh god it's the [ __ ] [ __ ] using the
Illuminati [ __ ] just happened
no thank you both so much for watching
this episode if you enjoyed please go
ahead and leave a like it supports me in
what I do and it saves you from demon
cows trying to harass you
thank you brother so much watching and
it's always stay awesome okay okay okay